mulder dificultad y velocidad estas son
las tres pruebas de la escalada
deportiva en el circuito profesional
cada una tiene sus campeones pero en el
programa olímpico las tres disciplinas
se combinaron
una federación internacional decidió
para evitar que una de las modalidades
quedara fuera hacer una mezcla de las
tres combinando las disciplinas por eso
es que hay estas tres pruebas los
atletas que participarán no son
especialistas de las 33 disciplinas muy
diferentes en dificultad escalar una vía
de 15 metros quien llegue más cerca de
la cima gana el búlder es más técnico
escalar el máximo de vías fijas en una
pared de 4.5 metros de altura la
velocidad es sencilla el primero en
llegar
en cada disciplina hay que llevar un
factor al máximo ser explosivo en
velocidad
el factor fuerza la imaginación y la
creatividad en boulder en dificultad el
esfuerzo es más largo entonces se
necesita capacidad de adaptación toma de
información y regulación si los atletas
están obligados a repasar lo aprendido y
funciona
se trata de autocontrol es como regresar
a la escuela para aprender una nueva
disciplina un nuevo deporte y con
paciencia y aplicación se logra progresa
la aplicación alguna vez ofrece a
mediados del siglo 20 los alpinistas se
reunieron en clubes para entrenarse e
intentar hacer sus cada vez más
peligrosos los muros artificiales
surgieron con las competiciones modernas
lo que permite preservar las paredes
naturales unos 40 años más tarde la
escalada llega a los juegos olímpicos
zaffaroni lo combine a beckett participe
el combinado las tres disciplinas es un
primer paso luego en parís en 2024 se
dará otro paso ya que se separa la
velocidad del búlder y la dificultad la
escalada es un deporte joven que tiene
cada vez más adeptos en el mundo su
objetivo que quede inscrita en la
aventura olímpica de manera permanente
[Aplausos]